Republicans who control the House
Intelligence Committee say they finished
investigating Russian election meddling
President Trump used capital letters to
appear just shout the committee's
conclusion on Twitter no evidence of
collusion or coordination between the
Trump campaign and Russia Geoff Piquet's
is on Capitol Hill with the disputed GOP
report Jeff good morning good morning
the house intelligence committees
Russian investigation has been hobbled
by partisan fights almost from the
beginning nearly fourteen months ago
after 73 interviews and nine hearings
and briefings as well as a review of
over 300 thousand documents Republicans
on the committee concluded that there
was no evidence of collusion between the
Trump campaign and Russians the GOP
members on the committee also disagreed
with the intelligence community's
January 2017 assessment that Russia's
meddling was partly because of Russian
President Vladimir Putin supposed
preference for candidate Trump Adams
shift the top Democrat on the committee
accused the Republicans of trying to
protect the president Democrats on the
committee will get a look at that draft
report later on today this Russia
investigation is not close to over it
continues in the Senate Intel committee
as well as the special counsels rustle
investigation that is ongoing as well in
a statement the spokesperson for the
Director of National Intelligence told
CBS News that the Intelligence Committee
stands by its January 2017 assessment
that Vladimir Putin had a preference for
president Trump do you have thanks many
more rounds to come in that
investigation